former senior counselor to president
trump kellyanne conway fox news
contributor joe concha kellyanne your
reaction
now you know why they don't let biden do
these press conferences
he didn't do well he's arguing with
reporters he's arguing about his polling
numbers which are very clear i mean just
today
sean and joe morning consult politico
poll came out with a report card on joe
biden but it's not joe biden's report
card on joe biden it's america's and 37
percent gave joe biden's first year in
office in f
a combined 31 gave him an a or a b
that's important because it takes an
awful lot for americans to want to fail
the president and the presidency we live
during these times we want we want the
country to be prosperous and successful
and intact and secure and people just
don't feel that so for two hours today
joe biden reinforced why he's an
unpopular president why his polling
numbers according to the gallup poll 40
percent approved 56 percent disapprove
after one year is the lowest on record
yes lower than donald trump's who did
not have the mainstream media pushing
for him covering for him and of course
voting for him i would have asked the
media a different question which is do
any of you regret voting for him do any
of you regret covering up stories about
his corrupt son do any of you regret not
pushing him more on the policies and the
issues and forcing him out of his
groundhog day basement when he was
campaigning or not campaigning because
this is this is what we have and it's a
serious point that his numbers have
cratered among independents even cnn had
to admit today sean that among
independents joe biden at this point a
year ago was over 60 percent he's now 33
approval among democrats he was at 98
percent one year ago he's at 82. so the
attrition is not just right-wingers and
conservatives and people who don't like
poor joe biden
it's all around now america also some of
them believe he's incapacitated but even
a higher number believe that he's
incompetent and i think the incompetence
measure is the most durable one because
it is a reflection on the entire
democratic party
until we change the policies and until
we change the president this country is
not going to get back on the track where
they were they missed the policies they
missed that america first agenda and
accomplishments that you ran through
because people felt more secure and more
prosperous and that they had more
opportunity they had more faith in the
office of the presidency joe on top of
the ukraine disaster and that now is
unfolding as a disaster um
you know president trump said something
to mark levine who interviewed him right
after the press conference and that is i
actually prefer he succeed
you know he's bragging about his
economic numbers but the average
american household is paying five
thousand dollar more five thousand
dollars more a year because of his
inflation that he caused
unless he reverses course that's not
going to change is it
and what we saw today from this press
conference sean was that he is not going
to reverse course it's like we heard the
same song again and again which he said
during the campaign and now as president
and when you watch any presidential
press conference you look for what are
the big three headlines you could take
out of it right and here's what i have
headline one biden says republicans will
change vote totals if voting legislation
doesn't pass wait i thought that such
rhetoric was chilling attacks on
democracy this is a president of the
united states sowing doubt in future
elections and every political pundit out
there who said it was wrong for the 45th
president when he did it is awfully
silent tonight as far as when joe biden
does it and it shows you how phony all
the outrage on tv was around that
headline two biden says he's
accomplished more in his first year than
any president in history given the
40-year inflation that you just
mentioned or given record violent crime
homicides or more than 2 million people
crossing the southern border illegally
that's a fascinating claim to make
speaking a crime despite two hours
dozens of questions not one not one on
violent crime impacting so many
americans i know peter ducey had that in
question too but he didn't have the
opportunity so here's where we are that
was an unmitigated disaster today sean
and those praising the president for
longevity of this press conference it's
all about quality not quantity as far as
the answers great great analysis
kellyanne and joe hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else